so we did this interview with a
psychiatrist a couple of months ago
called Trump's mental health is urgently
deteriorating and the topic was of
significant interest to our audience
about 350,000 views on YouTube I got at
least a hundred emails about that
interview and one really important
element of mental health professionals
making comments about what they see is
concerning in terms of Donald Trump's
behavior is that there is this sort of
conventional wisdom that you often hear
that you need to meet someone in person
in order to diagnose them that's true
for issuing a formal diagnosis but as
many mental health professionals have
explained to us over the last few months
there is enough audio-visual evidence
that mental health professionals can use
now to observe someone like president so
that they can make a pretty good
assessment of what might be going on
with one's cognitive state and potential
month mental illness or other
instabilities that one may be
experiencing and again it wouldn't be
something that would be used for a
formal diagnosis that would get an
insurance company to for example cover
SSRIs to diagnose someone via the
television but for the purposes of
evaluating what's going on with our
president it's actually a relatively
fair to do something like that and the
bad news is that it seems to be getting
worse both trumps mental state and the
opinions of mental health professionals
about that mental state seem to be
getting worse and when you look at the
books that have been written so far
about the Trump White House's inner
workings they all paint a pretty similar
picture which is one of a very erratic
and unstable Donald Trump a Bob Woodward
wrote in his book fear about a quote
nervous breakdown Michael Wolfe wrote in
fire and fury about a similar situation
we had that anonymous New York Times
op-ed from a White House official which
said that there were deep troubles in
the administration facing Donald Trump
and
mental health professionals are finding
themselves between our sort of two
conflicting policies which is you've got
that Goldwater rule which says diagnosed
people with their authorization and with
a personal in person examination up
against the duty to warn that mental
health professionals have overwhelmingly
increasingly mental health professionals
are saying that the duty to warn has to
take priority and there are now dozens
of co-authors of the book the dangerous
case of Donald Trump and thousands of
mental health professionals who are
agreeing with the books conclusions as
part of an organization called the
National Coalition of concerned mental
health experts and the conclusions are
that Trump is truly dangerous and I'm
not going to get into all the details
the book is very comprehensive it
includes assessments of Trump's tweets
his responses to questions in real time
during interviews and during press
conferences his narcissism his
recklessness his impulsivity and their
argument is that this isn't just
something that makes for sort of weird
press conferences that the behavior of
Trump represents a real threat when you
have him interacting with world leaders
and having access to the nuclear codes
check out the list of other risk factors
that they cite access to weapons poor
relationship with a spouse or
significant other seeing oneself as a
victim lack of compassion lack of
concern over the consequences of harmful
acts this is Trump this is Trump plain
and simple and this is aside from as the
mental health professionals point out
the cognitive decline concerns that we
and others have talked about many times
it's really important to understand that
if you don't buy the cognitive decline
argument and there are people in our
audience who don't and and they have
their reasons for not buying it this is
separate the duty to warn that mental
health professionals are expressing is
not limited to the cognitive decline but
rather to what seemed to be the
fundamental sort of behavioural
personality issues that this man is
dealing with but on the side on the
other side you've got that
pushing White House dr. Ronnie Jackson
who said Trump's fine because he was
able to figure out which drawing was of
a giraffe when presented with drawings
of a giraffe and a tiger the upside is
and this is sort of a really weird
silver lining the upside is that Trump
might only be a psychopath and what I
mean by that is that there's a higher
prevalence of psychopathy among
politicians and lots of the signs and
symptoms that I listed are similar to
those of psychopathy
so the best-case scenario here is that
Donald Trump might only be a psychopath